- Guys, here's the deal.
Entrepreneurship, you're
going to have highs.
You're going to have lows, I promise.
But as long as you get yourself back up
nothing can hold you back and stop you.
I was dead broke.
In was bankrupt.
In order to make ends meet,
I was driving a beer
cart at a country club.
Success, it's up to you.
Don't let anybody dictate what is
going to make you feel fulfilled
and what makes you feel happy.
I was pitching the Alpha M Style System.
- A to B to.
- A solid idea, but at $300
a pop for a fashion formula?
Customers just didn't bite.
- Shocking.
And neither did you.
- Hello Believe Nation,
I'm Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe.
And I believe that entrepreneurs
are going to solve all of the major
problems of the world.
So to help you on your journey,
today we're going to learn from men's
lifestyle expert Aaron Marino.
And my take on his top
10 rules for success.
Rule number three is my personal favorite.
And I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always, guys as you're watching,
if you hear something that really
resonates with you, please leave it
down in the comments below.
Put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired.
And when you write it
down, it's much more likely
to stick for yourself as well, enjoy.
(upbeat music)
- My name's Aaron Marino.
I am a men's lifestyle
expert and grooming guru.
And if you would have told me 10 years ago
that I would find so much happiness,
joy, and fulfillment
making videos on YouTube,
I would have punched you in the face.
My journey to finding this success,
and happiness, and voice, unfortunately
wasn't a straight line.
There were a lot of bumps
and turns along the way.
And they ultimately started, a broke kid
from Philadelphia whose
parents got divorced.
And I was raised with
an abusive stepfather.
I lost my ability to stand up for myself.
And so I kept everything inside.
I had all this anger,
hostility, and resentment.
My mom gave me a fitness
membership to a gym.
And when I went, I found my home.
It was the first time that
I felt like I belonged.
From the age of 13, I knew exactly
what I wanted to do with
the rest of my life.
I was going to own a fitness center.
I go to West Virginia
University, I graduate.
I met a guy, we opened
a few nutrition stores.
And ultimately that didn't work out,
because he was selling
drugs out of the back.
And I realized that prison wasn't a place
that I would flourish.
And so I left there and I met a woman
that I helped lose 100 pounds.
And she came to me and she said,
"Hey, I want to start a fitness center."
And this, for me was my dream.
And it was tough.
I didn't make much money.
It didn't matter because I was happy.
I was doing something that I loved.
We took some loans and got some investors.
There was a big issue
with one of our investors
and my business partner.
And it ultimately ended up in lots
of legal fights and battles.
We had to end up shutting
down this business.
I was dead broke.
I was bankrupt.
In order to make ends meet,
I was driving a beer
cart at a country club.
And I'm sitting there with tears
rushing down my face because
I don't know where to go.
I was at the lowest point
that I ever have been.
Giving up was never an option.
The problem was that I didn't know
what success looked like anymore.
But what I do have is a dream
and a desire to help people.
At the time there really wasn't anything,
any resources out there for regular guys
to get some solid, basic advice
on how to look good and feel great.
I decided that I was going
to help men feel better
and amazing about themselves.
So, I have a video camera.
I was the least tech savvy
person you'd ever meet.
But I picked it up and I decided
that I was going to try and film a video
and put it on YouTube.
Everything changed for me.
I found that new vision.
I found that new passion.
All of a sudden I had a
voice, I had an audience.
And I was doing something
that made me feel incredible.
Because I realized I was doing something
to help other people.
And with YouTube I was able to help
millions of men around the world
feel better about themselves.
That's what I was put on this Earth to do.
And I feel like true confidence
comes from helping other people.
All along I was searching for success.
I thought success was going to mean
a fitness center, a chain
of nutrition stores.
And I put myself aside and just focused
on the act of helping other people
feel better about themselves.
Everything in my life got better.
At the core of it, it's
just helping others.
Are you a risk taker?
Successful people are, but not just
random haphazard, like, "I'm driving
"drunk without my seatbelt type of risk."
I'm talking about calculated risks.
You weigh the options.
You weigh the potential
outcome, both good and bad
and you make the best decision possible.
But guys, I'm here to tell you
that you are never, ultimately
going to be successful unless you're
willing to put yourself out there.
Having the ability, or the willingness
to potentially fail,
is an absolute benefit.
And sometimes, these calculated risks
even though you thought about them,
sometimes they just don't work out.
And you know what successful people do?
"That's all right, I learned something.
"I know what not to do next time."
And you make another calculated risk.
Guys, nothing great was ever achieved
because it was easy.
So we talk all about the importance
of knowing who you are.
Having a secure sense of self is a key
component to the confidence equation.
"Who are you?
"What are you capable of?"
I've been asking myself this a lot lately.
And it seems like the more I ask,
the more I realize that over the course
of my life, I've been limiting myself
due to some arbitrary set of restrictions
or limitations that I've
put on myself years ago.
And I know that I'm not alone.
Why?
This is the question that I need you
to start asking yourself.
Why do we have these limitations?
What are our own personal limitations?
Gentlemen, it is time to stop
living like the elephant.
All right, now bear with me while
I explain this elephant analogy.
Okay, have you ever been to the circus?
Have you ever seen those
big, massive elephants?
They're held to the ground by this
little rope and a tiny little stake.
Are these elephants not strong enough?
Is this, like, Kryptonite rope
that these elephants are attached to?
No, of course not.
These elephants are bad ass.
One tug of the tusk, they
could be out of there,
and Delaware by dinner.
But they don't, why?
Because they've been
conditioned from a young age.
When the little baby
elephants join the circus.
I like to think of them as joining.
(laughs)
Poor elephants.
Anyway, I digress.
When these elephants are little,
they get to the circus and they
put a big strong rope on them
and they stake them to the ground.
Now, at the time, these little elephants
are like, "What the hell are you doing?"
And they start jumping, and dancing,
and trying to get loose but they can't.
Because they're little elephants.
And this is a strong rope
and a big strong stake.
So the elephant, after a while,
gets it in his head,
"Hey, I can't get loose."
And so they stop trying.
Because they know that
they can't get free.
Well, the elephant grows up.
The elephant gets to be a teenager.
And he's getting stronger,
he's been working out.
Then the elephant is an adult.
By this time he is massive.
He is strong.
He is capable of pulling out that stake
and getting lost, but he doesn't.
Because of his mindset.
Because he remembers when he was little,
he learned that he
couldn't and so he doesn't.
And much like the elephant.
The only thing holding us back.
The only limitations that we have
are these set of rules, or these things
that we have created for ourself.
These standards for ourselves
that we created years ago.
A lot of time, it's
five, 10, 30 years ago.
And just like the elephant,
we remained chained.
It's time to analyze, identify,
and give yourself the
permission to break the chains.
Gentlemen, we are so incredibly powerful.
The only thing that is holding you back,
holding me back in our life, and from
achieving whatever we want to achieve.
Are these preconceived
notions that we can't.
Was there somebody in your life that
told you that you couldn't?
That dissuaded you when, when you
were a little kid, right?
When you were a little kid what did
you want to be when you grow up?
An astronaut, everybody's
like, "A fireman.
"I want to be a police officer.
"I want to be a ballerina."
Whatever, don't look at me like that.
It was possible at the time.
But then what happens?
Through your years, as you grow,
people are telling you, "No."
People tell you, you can't.
All right, it is incredibly rare
to have and be surrounded by a nurturing
environment where the people in your life
tell you, "You can do
it, you can do anything.
"You can achieve, you can strive.
"You can go for the gold."
But so often, all right, it's these
negative people that stick out.
"You can't do that.
"You're not smart enough.
"You're not fast enough.
"You don't have the ability."
And we hear this and in the
back of our head we adopt it.
And we set these rules for ourselves,
these self imposed limitations.
Gentlemen, it's time to break the change.
Change, change, (laughs).
Do you have change for a dollar?
Where do you have
limitations in your life?
What is holding you back?
You're absolutely strong enough,
smart enough, fast
enough, confident enough.
Gentlemen, it's time to start living
with passion, with purpose.
Okay, I realize that
are things in our life,
we all have them, I have them.
We all struggle with that
negative thought in our head.
All right, these preconceived
notions, these limitations.
Listen, I believe in you.
You need to start believing in yourself.
It absolutely kills me
and breaks my heart,
whenever I see you guys and you're
not living up to your potential
because of your limitations.
And these limitations,
they're so arbitrary.
There's absolutely nothing
to them, no foundation.
Don't let other people set your
expectations of yourself.
Guys, you can do anything you want.
Break the chains and stop
living like an elephant.
One of the most eye opening pieces
of advice that I've ever received
was when I heard that we teach
people how to treat us.
This idea was groundbreaking to me.
And I started analyzing all of the
different relationships that I had.
And I realized that, absolutely,
I was teaching people that it was
okay to treat me a certain way.
Because I would never stand up for myself.
All right, there was a guy that I
opened some nutrition stores with
and I'd end up working more than I should
because I could never say, "No."
Or I want to make as
much money, make more.
Or because I never would
stand up for myself
and say, "No, I deserve it too."
Another reason that we as creatures
have such a tough time standing
up for ourselves is that we're
afraid of what will
happen if we actually do.
This was definitely the
case in my situation,
when I was growing up.
I was so petrified of having to move.
Change schools, change
friends, that's what I loved.
And it was easier for me just
to take it at home, as opposed to
have to potentially move.
And that's what the risk, I felt,
was if I would stand up and say,
"Hey, that's not okay."
Or if I would argue.
So, in my early 20s, I
realized that I had a problem.
My problem was the inability to
basically stand up for myself.
And it was really starting to bother me.
And so I decided to go see a therapist.
And it was one of the best
decisions I ever made.
But unfortunately, one of the things
I had to basically realize
and accept for myself,
is that if I wasn't comfortable
standing up for myself
in certain situations,
with certain people, I needed to
get out of those environments.
Because it was never going to get better.
The anxiety that I felt, even thinking
about standing up for
myself was way too much.
To me, it wasn't worth trying to
work it out with this guy
that I was in business with.
It was easier just to say,
"Deuces, I'm out," and leave.
Because that's the choice I made.
I don't know if it was right or wrong.
I feel good about it.
But a lot of times it is,
you've got to make a decision.
Sometimes you're going to lose friends.
Sometimes you're going to lose careers.
You could potentially lose a significant
other or spouse if you
finally stand up for yourself.
But the alternative is you
being eaten alive inside.
And that's just something I
wasn't willing to deal with.
And when I left, I basically said,
"Okay, if I'm going to be out of here
"I need to change.
"I need to make sure that I start
"asserting myself and
taking care of myself."
And so, I started doing it.
When I felt that I was
being treated poorly,
I'd say something.
Now one of the things that happened
is I would get crazy butterflies.
I would almost pass out.
I would get so much
adrenaline and get so nervous.
But it's like anything else.
If you practice, the more you practice,
the more you stand up for yourself.
You're going to find, the
easier it's going to get.
The other bonus and upside to standing
up for yourself is that these toxic
people and relationships,
seem to start going away.
Because they're comfortable
putting you down.
And if you're going to stand up they're
going to be like, "I don't want, no I'll
"go find somebody else who's a pushover."
One of the things that we do.
That totally prevents
us from moving forward
and excelling in our lives, careers,
relationships and
everything, is surrounding
ourselves with people that we really
probably shouldn't be associating with.
You are, all right, your success
is going to be the average of
the five people that you spend
the most time with during the day.
Now this is tough, all right.
Because think about it, right now.
Take an inventory of your
five closest friends.
Or the five people during the day
that you spend the most time with.
Are they losers?
Are you not exactly happy
with where you are right now?
Well guess what?
They're not going to
raise you up to the top.
They're not going to make you look better.
They're going to bring you down.
Successful people surround themselves
with successful people.
Me personally, you know who
I want to be friends with?
I want to be friends with people who
are smarter, that are more successful.
I want people that are
like, here, in my mind.
I want to be here, I
want to be the low man
on the totem pole.
Why?
Because I'm going to scurry up that
freaking ladder like a
squirrel chasing a nut.
All right, guys surround
yourself with successful people.
If you're currently hanging out
with people that don't have drive,
don't have motivation,
that are kind of losers,
lovable losers, but losers nonetheless,
re-evaluate your current
circle and adjust.
If this means you've got to cut some ties
or maybe not hang out
quite so much, it's okay.
If you need to seek out other people
to bring them into your
life, into your circle
I suggest you do that as well.
Success, as defined by Webster,
"Is achieving wealth, respect, or fame."
And I, personally, think
this definition sucks.
And is exactly the reason why
so many of us feel like failures,
because we haven't lived up to
some arbitrary set of success standards.
And so today I thought we'd take a
little bit of time and talk about success.
What it looks like to me.
And what it looks like to you.
Because, ultimately, you are the only one
who can define what
success looks like to you.
And I think it might
be time to re-evaluate.
We are taught from a young age to win.
All right, winning was success.
It was the goal.
Winning in sports, winning in your career,
winning at life.
The pursuit of life, liberty,
power, and a ton of money.
This is what I thought that success
was supposed to look like.
Well every time I analyze myself
and my accomplishments, I ended up
feeling like a failure.
Because I didn't have power.
I didn't have a lot of money.
And I didn't have fame.
And this is what I thought
it meant to be successful.
Because in my mind that's what everything,
everything in magazines, everything on TV.
If you were successful you got
tons of cash and you got tons of power.
Until one day I realized that I don't
care about those things.
All right, I don't want to be powerful.
That's not my goal.
I don't need tons of money.
As long as I have enough to
be comfortable, I'm cool.
Money wasn't my motivator.
So why would I tie my
feelings of success to it.
This realization rocked my world
and totally changed my
perception of everything.
And truly, it felt like a 1,000 pounds
success weight was lifted
off of my shoulders.
I felt amazing, I was free.
So once I realized that this wasn't
what success looked like, to me,
now I got to figure it out.
What does success look like?
What did I need to do?
What did I need to accomplish in order
to feel fulfilled and happy.
And I figured it out.
And this is what success looks like to me.
My professional success meant that
I was doing something that I loved.
That I was able to touch other peoples'
lives and make a difference.
Personally, I was successful if have
relationships with
those people that I love
that were deep and meaningful.
Nothing was left off the table.
You let people know how you feel.
You communicate and reciprocate the love.
Financial success, just meant that
I had enough money.
That I didn't need to worry about money.
Not saying like, "Hey, I can go and buy
"whatever I want because I don't really
"have very expensive tastes."
Meaning that, if I live modestly
I don't have to worry about making
it paycheck to paycheck.
Emotional success to me meant that
I was in touch with my feelings,
my emotions, and that I was good
with the person I saw looking
back at me in the mirror.
It was all about having a
solid character and confidence.
If I can achieve those four things,
and not only achieve
them but maintain them,
let me tell you something.
To me that is success.
Every day when I wake up,
that is what I focus on.
I focus on being successful
and what it means to me.
It doesn't mean that I have a ton of cash.
It doesn't mean that I have power,
or fame, or worldly riches.
No, but to some people that's
what success looks like,
just not to me.
So I wanted to share my story.
To tell you, sort of, the journey
that I took in order to identify
and realize what success
actually meant to me.
And I would encourage you to take
the time to figure it out for yourself.
The first thing you need to do.
And the first step is throwing out
all those preconceived notions.
All of the things you've been
bombarded with from your parents,
from society, from social media,
from TV, from movies, from everywhere.
Throw it out, it doesn't matter.
You get to start blank, clean slate.
And figure out what
success looks like to you.
Maybe success is you living on a beach.
Being able to get up every morning
and paint the ocean.
I don't know, maybe success to you
is having a family, having little kids
running home to you and just being a dad.
Success, it's up to you.
Don't let anybody dictate what is
going to make you feel fulfilled
and what makes you feel happy.
Guys, do it now.
Figure it out, write it down.
And then every single
morning you get up and focus.
Focus on what it's going to take
to make you feel whole
and feel successful.
This, my friends, is a gift.
And once you figure it out you are
going to be amazed at how good it feels
and how successful you become.
The first place you need to start,
when trying to become a
better man is attitude.
It's all about changing your
mindset and perspective.
All right, right now you're feeling
a little bit crappy.
You're like, "I'm not good enough.
"I've got low self esteem."
Here's the deal.
You need to focus on all of the amazing,
positive, attributes that
you possess, all right?
Change your mindset, you
will change your attitude.
Because I tell you, you can have
all the nicest clothes in the world,
all the money, all the cars, everything.
If you've got a crappy
attitude none of it matters.
Your mindset, your
attitude, about yourself,
about ourselves, that is
the hardest thing to change.
But the thing, that once you get it,
everything else seems to fall in place.
Confidence, this is what
Alpha M was all about.
And what I would come to realize was
the reason that I was put on this Earth.
To help guys feel better about themselves.
It's (laughs), it's hard
for me to talk about.
This passion and this desire to help you
burns so deeply inside of me.
And I feel it through every
ounce of my body and soul.
Confidence, this is the key to feeling
great about yourself.
Without it you will absolutely never know
your true potential, or how amazingly
powerful you could possibly be.
So when I realized that
it was this confidence
that I wanted to try and
facilitate in other people,
I told some people about it.
And they're like, "You
can't teach confidence.
"Either you have it or you don't."
And these were people that I did respect.
And so it sort of got to me a little bit.
And I thought to myself, "Hey, maybe you
"can't teach or maybe you
can't learn confidence."
They told me, "Just stick to style.
"Don't talk about this other stuff."
But I decided that I wanted to
keep talking about the other stuff.
Talk about things that I felt were
important to develop character.
Because I really did
feel like, "Hey, maybe
"it's going to help at least one person."
And then something remarkable happened.
I got an email.
It's from a guy who watched my videos.
His name was Brian.
And he told me that
through watching my videos,
he actually felt better about himself
and that he was more confident.
And this was like, "What?"
I'm like, "Really?"
It was the best day of my life.
And something else strange happened.
I got another one.
And another one, and another one.
Gentlemen, I realized that I was right.
You absolutely can learn to be confident.
Validation, confidence is
a skill, it can be learned!
But now came the tricky part.
I needed to figure out a structure
and a system how to actually walk
somebody through the steps
to become more confident.
It's taken me two years to
complete but I finally did it.
Gentlemen, I am incredibly proud
and pleased to announce, that the Alpha M
Confidence Course is complete.
The Alpha M Confidence Course is a
step by step system to help you unlock
the five phases of self confidence.
Phase one is learning and exploration.
You've got to be able to
take a hard look at yourself.
Ask yourself the tough questions,
in order to drill down to figure out
who you are as a person and what has
led you to where you are now, as a person.
Until you understand who you are,
you can never move forward.
Phase two is developing your physical
and external confidence.
Fitness, style, grooming, diet.
All of these topics are discussed,
in detail, and outlined in phase two.
Think of it as confidence
from the outside.
You work on the outside, it
transcends to the inside.
And then Phase three is all about
acting and communicating confidently.
Phase four is living confidently.
And then we're wrapping
it up with Phase five
which is adoption.
But here's the interesting
thing about confidence.
Any skill for that matter.
Is that you need to
continually nurture it.
And do the things that you did
in order to get to that
level of confidence.
So if you get to be confident,
feeling good about yourself, right?
If you stop doing all those other things
that led you to here, guess what?
The insecurity's going to creep in.
Confidence is not a thing.
It's not a destination.
It's a journey that you're
going to be on your entire life.
That's it guys, I got in trouble.
After the gym I go home.
I eat, I shower, and I sit on the couch
and work a little bit
more, until about 10:00.
Then a go to bed, sleep for around
seven hours and do it all over again.
I know that from the outside, looking in,
it might seem like I'm always working,
but I don't feel like that.
I feel, honestly, like I'm the luckiest
guy in the world.
This point in my life and my career,
I still love what I do.
And every single day I get up
and I am so excited to take on the day.
And to create content and to work
and create businesses
and it's just incredible.
- [Announcer] First up is an entrepreneur
from season four, returning to The Tank,
with a new opportunity for the sharks.
(dramatic instrumental music)
- Hello Sharks, my name is Aaron Marino.
And I'm here today seeking
a $100,000 investment,
for 10% equity stake in my
new company Pete & Pedro.
So if I look familiar to you, it's
because I've been here before.
But last time I was pitching
the Alpha M Style System.
- A to B to.
- A solid idea, but at $300
a pop for a fashion formula?
Customers just didn't bite.
- Shocking.
- Neither did you.
- Thank God.
- But you gave me something more valuable.
A new direction and life changing advice.
See, I knew you were right.
I needed a lower price point product,
something that every guy needed and used.
Well about a month after
I was on Shark Tank
there I am, styling my hair,
when inspiration struck,
and Pete & Pedro was born.
A new line of super awesome,
men's hairstyling products.
Pete & Pedro equals bueno hair.
We're selling direct to the consumer,
which means a higher quality
product at a great price.
Guys buy it, they try it, they love it.
And sign up for the Bueno Hair Club,
where we automatically ship them
their favorite Pete & Pedro product
every four, six, or eight weeks.
Look Sharks, I'm back.
This time, with a product
that men need and love.
And I'm not walking out of
here again without a deal.
So who's ready to partner with me
and share the hair?
Gentlemen, what's happening guys?
Thank you so much for watching this video.
But really I think I
owe the biggest thanks
to a Josue O'Remiggio.
Sorry for butchering the name brother.
But he is the one who actually recommended
or asked Evan to do this video on me.
And I can't tell you how incredibly
humbled and honored I am to
be on, Evan, your channel.
Because you're doing
some incredible things
for incredible guys.
Guys, here's the deal.
Entrepreneurship, you're
going to have highs,
you're going to have lows, I promise.
But as long as you get yourself back up
nothing can hold you back and stop you.
And before I go I would just like
to leave you with this.
Something that I learned along the way.
And that is, that success doesn't
always look like what you expect
or what you hope it will.
Keep your eyes open.
Realize that sometimes the universe
has a different direction.
So make sure that you listen, both
with your eyes and ears.
And that was super cheesy.
(laughs)
But anyway guys, thank you so much,
keep rocking and rolling
and move forward gentlemen.
You got this!
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Josue O'Remiggio asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
check out the link in the description.
And go and cast your vote.
I also want to give a quick shout out
to Joshua Rodriguez, Joshua thank you
so much for picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
Doing the collaboration with me
and tweeting that fun picture as well.
I really appreciate the support, man.
And I'm glad you enjoyed the read.
So thank you guys, again, for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
- True story, when I
had my fitness centers,
it got pretty bad towards the end.
I expanded too fast.
There were a bunch of internal issues.
Remember I was saying,
"Choose your partners wisely."
It got so bad, financially, for us
that I was having to take money
off of credit cards in
order to pay my employees.
And so, in order to make ends meet
I had to take a second job on weekends,
working as a beer cart
girl on a golf course.
So, private, members only golf course.
And there was a moment when, there were
lots of moments doing
that, but it was Winter.
It was February.
And in Atlanta it does get cold,
especially at 6:30 in
the morning, on a Sunday.
There was frost.
It was about 23 degrees and there was
no heat in the cart.
And so I'm sitting there waiting
for golfers to come around.
There's no shelter, I'm just in this cart,
shivering my butt off.
And it was that critical moment,
in my life, when I realized that,
"My God, I will do anything it takes
"in order to be successful."
The walls, my empire that I had planned on
building and creating was crumbling
right before my eyes.
And there I am sitting in a beer cart
a 32 year old dude, serving
beer to drunk golfers.
Swallow your pride.
If you're going to do things, know that
you're going to do it and
times could get tough.
You give up too easily.
When the tough gets going,
you do something else.
Because the thought of actually
having to persevere
and work through things
is too much for you to handle.
If you are somebody who gives up
way too easy, you get any
slight hint of resistance
in any capacity, you're like,
"Whatever, I didn't want that anyway."
And you're on to the next thing.
If this is you, you are never going
to ultimately achieve your goals
and the desired success level
that you're striving for.
Now I know that I personally have
experienced quite a bit of
disappointment in my life.
And I'm assuming that you have, as well.
And guess what, we're going to continue
to be disappointed throughout out lives.
At least we should be.
Because If you're not, that means
that you're really not trying.
Now how you handle yourself
post-disappointment,
this is critical to your
emotional and mental well being.
Pain, pain, hurting, right?
It's part of the growing process.
But I'll tell you something.
Life has a funny way of closing doors
in order to keep you moving
in the right direction.
So often in our society and
as people we run from pain.
We do everything we can
to protect ourselves
and to shield ourselves
from feeling uncomfortable.
That feeling of pain.
And this is the reason why so many
people abuse drugs, alcohol, casual sex.
We do this to not feel the pain.
But I'm saying, "Stop running.
"Stop trying to mask it."
When you feel pain,
disappointment, it's okay.
Don't try and cover it up.
What you should do is actually embrace it.
I know, it's easy for me sitting here
and saying, "Oh embrace the pain.
"You're feeling like crap?
"Don't worry about it.
"Feel it, feel it."
I get it, right?
That's kind of a long shot.
But what I'm saying is that the pain
is normal, it's natural, it's a part
of the growth process.
Learn from it, once you do, you accept it,
you embrace it, learn from it,
and put it in its' place, you're going to
be able to move forward,
stronger, faster, smarter.
If you're not struggling and getting
disappointed from time to time,
this probably means that you're not
really pushing your limits too far.
All right, it's okay, embrace it,
don't get discouraged, and stay focused.